good afternoon class of 2016
you
first starters I think I owe you an
apology I know what you were thinking
2014 John Kerry 2015 Joe Biden then 2016
rolls around and your class day speaker
still hasn't been announced and you
start thinking okay Secretary of State
then vice president who else would
follow naturally in the hierarchy and
then boom you get the US ambassador to
what biggest disappointment since they
canceled safety dance or to get more
specific as one of your classmates
summed it up on Facebook yeah thanks
how come 2014 and 2015 got Kerry and
Biden and we get this Rando
so sorry sorry for being the Rando thank
you
thank you it's okay really it's okay
since I went to school here right here I
have been blessed to be able to do some
pretty amazing things
none more extraordinary than getting to
serve every day as the American
ambassador to the United Nations but
getting to be back at Yale with you on
this day is a life highlight it is an
honor to speak at any university on such
a day but this is no ordinary University
this is Yale and I am floored and very
very humbled three special shout outs
first to the parents stepparents and
other loved ones of the graduates let's
give them a huge round of applause for
all they have sacrificed to make this
weekend and in many ways this life
possible second I have to give a special
Congrats to the Davenport grads because
some colleges some colleges are more
equal than others and finally a shout
out of commiseration to the seniors from
Saybrook
who I gather word travels I gather have
had a rough year especially when it
comes to laundry too soon what when I
sat where you are sitting today more
than two decades ago or as you may think
of that time not long after Homo sapiens
began to walk upright and the tectonic
plates came together to form the
Himalayas the Yale Bowl and Science Hill
I would never have imagined that I an
Irish immigrant and Atlanta Public High
School grad would one day get the chance
to come back to Yale in this capacity
never indeed when I was a days freshman
holed up in Bingham right over there or
grabbing lunch in Commons sorry Commons
at the schwartzman Center sorry
or spending my senior year in front in
McLellan as a freshman counselor right
there if in any one of those
incarnations if someone had tried to
tell me that I would one day be Yale
class day speaker I would have said that
they had clearly been taking Morrie's
punch intravenously this would have seen
seemed even more unlikely than my
beloved Red Sox winning three World
Series in the decade even lower odds
than an african-american whose first
name was one consonant removed from the
world's most infamous terrorists
becoming president and just about as
inconceivable as it becoming the law of
the land in America that anyone can
marry the person they love
but somehow Here I am I have received
two monumental breaks in my life without
which I would not be here the first came
when I was nine and my mother decided to
bring my younger brother Steven and me
to the United States from Dublin Ireland
the second came in 1988 when I arrived
home from high school basketball
practice in Atlanta one day to find that
my then 13 year old brother had laid out
all the college admissions letters on
our dining room table including a thick
manila envelope with the capital Navy
wide and a New Haven return address
telling me that against all odds I had
been accepted here at that time I had
never before even visited the Northeast
I got to admit I was far from a
superstar here at Yale I had been an
avid basketball player in high school
but I wasn't good enough to play on the
Yale varsity team though now thanks to
Ben and cation I can wear the jersey and
tell people I did
but I didn't make the cut I became
instead a fanatical intramural sports
player and this is rather embarrassing
to unearth but I was actually voted by
my senior year Davenport classmates not
most likely to succeed but most likely
to come back from the intramural fields
with bloody knees that was an actual
award they gave out I think it hasn't
been given out since I hope I also tried
my hand at sports reporting for the Yale
Daily News now you might be thinking
Samantha power eventual contributor to
The Economist's and the New Yorker turns
to writing at Yale and discovers she's a
natural well thanks to the internet we
can let some of my early reporting speak
for itself here's how I opened my very
first article in September 1988 just
having arrived on campus quote
volleyballs aren't the only things high
up in the air this week for the women's
volleyball team so our expectations and
spirits end quote
ouch
or consider this I really got better
quickly March 1989 quote the a cappella
groups something extra sang the national
anthem before Saturday nights Yale
Cornell woman women's basketball game
and the blue were well aware that it
would take something extra or rather
something extraordinary for them to win
end quote
really early in my sophomore year I was
briefly given a sports column called
power play whose name judging from my
abuse of puns in the other articles was
probably my idea mercifully it seems
only to have run a couple times but
instead of throwing myself into
journalism I mostly held back I wrote
articles the way I wrote my class papers
last minute without investing the time
or energy it takes to get better when
you risk little you can't be
disappointed if you don't excel you are
not failing to thrive you just aren't
trying these were my unconscious alibis
and then at the end of my freshman year
here a pair of lightning bolts hit the
first came in a class during my freshman
spring professor Victor Lustig was
teaching an advanced seminar on modern
Irish literature which I'd managed to
talk my way into I had signed up for the
course because I'd already read most of
the books and figured I could coast
through one being originally Irish at
the end of the year I walked to the
professor's office right over there in
LC and I fished my paper out of the pile
and found a long handwritten note on the
last page the note was utterly
eviscerating professor left aghhhhhh
called me out for never making a serious
effort questioning why i had fought for
a seat in the class when i
care to do the work and he talked about
how disrespectful it was to the other
students to the literature and most of
all to myself I walked into the
professor's office and I held up his
note this is harsh
I said you deserved it he shot back and
he was right and the same judgment
really could have been made about my
entire freshman year here I hadn't put
my heart into it and although I wasn't
conscious of doing so
I was keeping myself at a distance I
could remain the carefree outsider never
getting hurt because I would never make
myself vulnerable by going all in the
second lightning bolt struck just a few
weeks later when I was back in Atlanta
where I had lined up a summer internship
with the local CBS Sports affiliate I
was sitting in a video booth taking
notes on a Braves Padres game when I
spotted something out of the corner of
my eye coming from another live feed it
was from Tiananmen Square in China where
students my age your age had gathered to
ask their governments their government
to grant them fundamental freedoms and I
watched frozen with my clipboard in hand
as tanks rolled into the square and
soldiers opened fire on the protesters
watching those students who were risking
their freedom and even their lives for
their rights brought home just how
little I had put on the line I knew that
I wanted to be all in for something and
to do what little I could to help people
who were fighting for their dignity and
while I didn't yet know what that meant
or how I was going to do it or whether I
could do it my compass
had been reset so when the iconic photo
of the man standing in front of a tank
in Tiananmen Square appeared on the
cover of Time magazine I tore it out and
put it up in my dorm room as a reminder
of what it meant
take real risks the worst that could
happen to me at Yale was that I would
study zealously and end up with a
middling grade what was so risky about
that I share this personal experience
with you because when someone is
introduced at an event like this one the
bio often implies that they have walked
a linear and preordained path to get
where they are nobody tells you that
your class day speaker wrote a
remarkably mediocre sports column with a
lame name in the college paper that was
discontinued your class chairs didn't
open up Samantha Power's spent her
freshman year at Yale mailing it in and
wondering whether she deserved to be
here but everyone has voices in their
heads that tell them that everyone else
is more capable I even have a name for
the place where those voices live I call
it my bat cave bats flying around call
it what you want everybody's got one a
healthy dose of self-doubt is a good
thing it is the sister of humility which
is a great thing the trick is not
letting the voices that live in your
Batcave hold you back from pursuing your
path and that was what I realized at the
end of my freshman year here I didn't
want to go through my time at Yale or
anywhere else giving myself alibis for
not trying to change at least my little
slice of the world especially when there
were people out there who were risking
so much more but my question was how was
I going to do that and that's what I
want to speak to you about today my
message is no matter what you choose to
do with your life if you truly want to
live fully and leave the world a little
better than you found it you have to get
close the great photographer Robert Capa
who shot some of the most iconic photos
of the second world war
or put it this way if your pictures
aren't good enough you aren't close
enough now rest assured parents the
message of your child's graduation
speech is not go stand in front of a
tank or go report on a civil war but the
message is that if you want to have a
deep impact on what matters to you don't
do things at remove invest yourself
fully get close now what does that even
mean first getting close means moving
beyond approaching an issue through the
screen on your laptop or phone or the
filter of someone else's interpretation
and instead finding a way to get to know
the individuals whose lives are impacted
by hearing people's experiences
firsthand whether the people who live in
your buildings if you become an
architect the people if who work for you
if you run a small business or big
business for that matter or the people
who are suffering injustice if you
become a full-time advocate you will see
what cannot later be unseen you don't
have to look far for models of how to do
this I found my own in my own home my
mother is a kidney doctor and I've never
seen anyone relate to the people she's
treating in the way that she does when I
was a kid she would come home and share
such vivid details about the lives of
her patients details that had nothing to
do with their physical conditions that
it was as if the patient's themselves
were telling jokes and sharing their
sagas at the dinner table with us she
got close my father who's here today is
retired but always a devourer of history
he became a continuing education student
not that long ago at Columbia University
and recently has decided to explore the
history of Islam when he stays overnight
at our apartment to help babysit my kids
I can hear the loud and persistent
scrape of his pencil
his history and theology texts from the
next room deep into the night he brings
his professors and his classmates to the
UN gallery when we have public sessions
of the UN Security Council on Syria or
Iran I've been lucky enough to wear a
number of different professional hats
over my career and with each one getting
close has made me care more about and
get better at what I worked at soon
after I graduate from Yale I became
consumed with the conflict at the time
in the Balkans and decided to move to
Bosnia to try to report on the war's
devastating human consequences as a
journalist there I had occasion to
interview Bosnian families religious
leaders and militia as well as UN
peacekeepers and humanitarians when I
was in academic researching American
foreign policy getting close men
interviewing hundreds of policymakers
who had made the decisions I was
studying in order to try to understand
their calculus and of course as a
diplomat I try to get out to the field
as often as I can to meet people whose
lives are affected by US and UN policies
whether that's the doctors and nurses
running an Ebola treatment clinic or a
Nigerian girl struggling to rebuild her
life after having been abducted by Boko
Haram this brings me to my second point
to really get close to an issue you must
seek out ways to see the world and its
problems from a radically different
perspective from the one that comes
naturally to you this is hardly a new
challenge for example a previous Yale
class day speaker lamented the fact that
quote we subject all facts to a
prefabricated set of interpretations we
enjoy the comfort of opinion without the
discomfort of thought and quote that was
John F Kennedy in 1962 but the problem
has only become worse from the Facebook
and Twitter feeds we monitor to the
algorithms that determine the results of
our web searches based on our previous
browsing history and local
our major sources of information are
increasingly engineered to reflect back
to us the world as we already see it
they give us the comfort of our opinions
without the discomfort of thought so you
have to find a way to break out of your
echo chambers this is tougher than it
sounds especially when it comes to the
issues you care most about but it is in
your interest to engage the people you
disagree with rather than shutting them
out or shutting them up not only because
it gives you a chance to challenge their
views and maybe even change them but
also because sometimes they may just be
right when I started as the US
ambassador to the UN three years ago I
made up my mind that since I wouldn't be
able to travel to every country in the
world truly getting close I'd at least
try to visit as many ambassadors from
192 other UN member states as I could I
decided that I didn't want to go into
the meetings with a set of asks as I
normally do I just wanted to get to know
a little more about the issues that
mattered most to them how they had
become diplomats what books and
keepsakes they had brought with them all
the way from home and the art and photos
they had chosen to put up on their walls
so far I visited the ambassador's of 164
countries the Ambassador from Zambia
told me how hiv/aids had ravaged her
country a pediatrician before becoming a
diplomat she said that at the peak of
the epidemic she could hardly rally
herself to go to work in the morning
because as she put it there was nothing
I could do to help my babies but she
cared too much to quit at the Cuban
mission to the UN which I was the first
US ambassador to visit in a half century
photographs of Che Guevara and Fidel
Castro still lined the halls the
ambassadors of many small island nations
have told me about witnessing climate
change transform their countries in
their lifetimes seeing the villages
where they grew up completely flooded
one of these ambassadors brought
steak's home to me recently and
unforgettably he said I just don't know
where all of my people will go who will
take us now imagine if you live on a
small island state imagine what that
means and what your future looks like
third if you really want to make change
it's rarely enough to get close yourself
you also have to bring others close with
you helping them see issues that can
otherwise feel far removed or invisible
in their daily lives consider here the
work of one of your classmates Sarah
Josje a Syrian American where's Sarah I
hope she's at class day hi Sarah
Sarah probably didn't know this was
coming Sarah is a Syrian American who
made multiple trips to volunteer in
refugee camps and clinics along the
border with Syria where she witnessed
firsthand all the needs that were going
unmet from undersupplied medical clinics
to schools that didn't have room to take
in more kids in her sophomore year she
and other students raised more than
thirty thousand dollars to aid Syrian
refugees and support hospitals still
operating in Syria but Sarah and her
fellow students didn't just rally
support they also brought what was
happening to Syrians close to people
here at Yale like the time in December
when they blanketed the quad across
campus with miniature flags each of
which represented approximately fifty
thousand displaced Syrians or like the
time when they drew the chalk outlines
of footsteps along walkways all around
campus making visible the millions of
miles that Syrians have traveled to seek
refuge in neighboring countries through
these and so many other actions Sarah
and other students made people see the
millions of Syrian refugees not as
abstract masses but as individuals just
like them just like us and in so doing
motivated more people to get involved
my fourth and final point is that
getting close and staying close requires
patience and impatience at once look at
the history of any great rights struggle
and you will see that when it moved
forward at all
it was always in a two steps forward one
and a half steps back fashion or as the
late great un diplomat Sergio Vieira de
Mello put it history is not in a hurry
so if you are setting out to make a
slice of the world better you must go in
knowing that real change often requires
a long struggle that doesn't mean being
patient in the face of injustice because
while history may not be in a hurry you
can and you must
speed it up indeed the struggle to
advance basic human rights has almost
always been driven by people who refuse
to accept that any one of us should have
to wait until tomorrow for the dignity
that every one of us deserves today it
is because history is not in a hurry
that we must always bring a healthy
skepticism to claims that the great
right struggles are behind us and that
we have mostly achieved the Equality we
seek few have rebutted this myth more
eloquently than Franklin and here I'm
not talking about Benjamin Franklin or
Aretha Franklin
but the late african-american historian
John Hope Franklin born in 1915 John
Hope Franklin played a key role on the
n-double-a-cp team that brought the case
for brown v board of education but his
greatest contribution was his life's
work documenting the history of slavery
and its enduring and deeply corrosive
impact on American life here's what
Franklin said in 1992 not long after the
police's beating
Rodney King set off the LA riots quote a
colorblind society does not exist in the
United States and never has existed
those who insist we should conduct
ourselves as if such a utopian state
already existed have no interest in
achieving it and indeed would be
horrified if we even approached it end
quote
again those who insist we should conduct
ourselves as if such a utopian state
already existed have no interest in
achieving it and indeed would be
horrified if we even approached it that
was true in 1992 and it is true in 2016
and it applies not only to enduring
racial issues that have been brought to
the surface in places like Ferguson
Baltimore and Cleveland but to so many
other persistent forms of inequality and
Prejudice take the ongoing struggle for
women's equality now no one can dispute
the progress made in the world in this
country in this university here is what
the freshman handbook said in 1970 two
years after Yale first admitted women
treat Yale as you would a good woman
take advantage of her many gifts nourish
nourish yourself with the fruit of her
wisdom cursor if you will but
congratulate yourself in your possession
of her Wow
simply Wow so a lot has changed but
while so much has changed
consider this while Yale was founded
roughly three-quarters of a century
before our nation declared its
independence Yale like the United States
has never had a woman president except
for the great scholar Hannah gray who
held the role temporarily for a year
when her predecessor left suddenly
another data point since I graduated way
back in 1992 only four other women have
been your class day speaker which makes
sense in a way because it's not as
though there are any amazing women out
there who attended Yale I mean it's not
like the first ever Latina Supreme Court
justice went to Yale or the first woman
to chair the Federal Reserve or the
woman who designed our nation's
transcendent Vietnam War Memorial so I
get it amazing Yale women grads are hard
to find
but more important than this of the 669
women graduating today I'm willing to
bet that every one of you knows what it
feels like to be treated differently
because you are a woman many of the same
dynamics play themselves out at the
United Nations of the 15 countries with
a seat on the UN Security Council only
one the United States is represented by
a woman 1 for 15 in 2016 the UN is
currently in the process of selecting a
new secretary-general a position that in
the organization's 70 year history has
never been held by a woman not long ago
I was discussing the race with another
ambassador to the UN and I made the
point that it is important that women be
encouraged to apply in response this
ambassador asked do you want to look at
a pretty girl or do you want someone who
can actually get the job done for women
I was shocked but maybe I shouldn't have
been by the way it's not like the u.s.
government has figured this out either
consider our national security workforce
which I hope many of you will join one
day minorities still make up less than
20% of senior diplomats and less than
15% of senior military and intelligence
officials that is an imbalance that
deprives us of some of our nation's
brightest minds and addressing it is a
national security imperative my point is
not that the UN Yale or the u.s.
national security establishment have
done a particularly poor job of
embracing diversity my point is that the
enduring inequalities we see in
institutions like these reflect systemic
injustice --is that persist in our
societies to the detriment not only of
the people who are subjected
- discrimination but to all of us and
acting as if we have overcome these
entrenched biases is part of the problem
- the vast majority of you this is
obvious to some of you it is something
you have experienced personally you may
come from a country where you cannot
openly practice your religion without
risking attacks or persecution you may
have felt it on this very campus when
the gate to your residential college was
closed and locked as you walked toward
it you may may have felt it living in a
college name for a man who once argued
that enslaving your ancestors was a
positive good
you may have felt it
upon hearing us politicians call on our
country to ban people of your faith so
when you hear people claim that the work
is finished you say not for me it's not
not for us
and some of you have poured a lot of
yourselves into these and other
struggles over the past four years if
you have you might look at all that
remains unchanged and feel discouraged
whether that's inside Yale with the name
of a college that did not change or a
faculty that doesn't look as diverse as
you and the rest of America or outside
Yale in the horrific plight of refugees
whose situation only seems to get worse
despite all that you and your classmates
have done to try to make it better but
whether serving others is your full time
job or a part time vocation setbacks
like these are not just probable they
are inevitable and the more you get
close the more of yourself you put into
these struggles and the more you make
yourself vulnerable
the harder these setbacks will hit you
the more they will hurt but the progress
that you make in advancing the rights of
others and you will make progress will
more than sustain you because in
fighting for the dignity of others you
will find a humbling yet profound sense
of your own worth that is a lesson I
take from the life of Paula Murray a
Yale grad who dedicated her life to
struggles for equality and human dignity
now I admit that I hadn't heard of
Murray before Yale decided to name a
residential hall in her honor in
learning about her what struck me was
not only how ahead of her time she was
in the struggles for equality that she
waged it was also how often she lost
despite being on the side of what was
right in 1938 she applied but was denied
admission from the University of North
Carolina because she was black in 1940
she refused to move to the back of a bus
and was detained and then refused to pay
a fine for disobedience and went to jail
not long after she joined the legal
defense team of a black sharecropper who
she believed had been unjustly sentenced
to death by an all-white jury they lost
the case and then lost the appeal and
the man was executed in 1942 those are
just a few of the painful losses Murray
endured there were so many more yet
while it often looked like in that
moment as if Murray had lost history
shows us that even in these losses she
moved the struggle forward bringing
injustice out into the open exposing its
ugliness and chipping away at its
foundation little by little
let me read you something Murray said in
an interview later in her life
reflecting back on these efforts in not
a single one of these little campaigns
was i victorious in other words in each
case I personally failed but I have
lived to see the thesis up upon which I
was operating vindicated and what I very
often say is that I've lived to see my
lost causes found I've lived to see my
lost causes found many of the struggles
for equality that Murray dedicated her
life to are ones we continue to grow
with to this day who better than you to
carry them forward so graduating class
of 2016 as you embark on what I hope
will be a life of embracing struggles
like these this is my message to you get
close go all in get close to the people
affected by your work seek out
perspectives different from your own and
work to bring others close with you know
that history is not in a hurry but that
you can help speed it up and recognize
that while the journey will be long and
you will lose and lose again it is the
struggle itself that will define you do
that and you will know not only find
yourself fulfilled but you too will live
to see many of your lost causes found
congratulations class of 2016 we can't
wait to see all the causes you will find
thank you you're counting on you
thank you
you